So one of the most important sort of components
of social democracy, which is the political
ideology that I most align with, is that we
see certain areas of life, certain areas of
an economy as deserving of being outside of
the for profit system. A social democracy
is capitalism, but it is capitalism with limits.
It's capitalism with the fruits of that system
reinvested significantly in making sure that
no one falls too low in terms of their status
in, in the world and the economy in, in society.
Uh, and there are certain areas that often
come up as deserving to be outside of that
for-profit system. Health care is very often
one. Education is very often one and one that
has been more discussed lately but, but less
frequently is doing something about housing.
How should we deal with housing and with so
much negative news, like a lot of this stuff
we're talking about is bad.
Things that have happened, I have today just
a really great policy proposal to discuss
from Bernie Sanders relating to housing. It
says housing for all plan that he released
yesterday. And there's a view about housing
that is we should totally de commodify housing,
completely remove it from the marketplace,
set up some kind of land value tax that would
equal the rental value of properties so that
people can still own private property. We're
not saying no more ownership of private property,
a real estate that, that being a but seeking
rent on property will be pointless because
whatever amount of rent you earn, you will
have to pay a land value tax equivalent to
that. Now potentially you would still get
the value of owning the property, but you
would get that either way. Uh, now there are
also that may that understandably will sound
extreme to some people in the audience.
There are less extreme versions than totally
socializing ownership of real estate, of,
of all housing. And uh, the truth is that
if you hear me talking about this and you
say, David, you're not going far enough. We
should de commodify all housing and put a
land value tax equivalent to the rental value
of any property. That's not going to happen
anytime soon. I think most people would agree.
Whether you like that or not, that's a debate,
but it's not happening anytime soon. So the,
the immediate thing that we should look at
doing is what is actually doable, which is
socially democratic programs that will seriously
deal with homelessness and the rising cost
of living across the United States. Bernie
Sanders has now released such a proposal and
it's a very solid one and I want to talk about
it with you today. The premise is that we
have a situation where it's frankly that we
have homelessness in the United States.
We're a rich country. We have the money financially.
We can end homelessness, homelessness in the
United States, we should consider homes or
place to live or right. Cost of living is
out of control, rent seeking and gentrification
at the hands of wealthy developers and landowners
and rich people. It hurts so many people and
Bernie Sanders plan deals with a lot of this.
Now I'm just going to give you some of the
highlights. I know some people will say, I
missed some important elements of this. There
are more than 30 provisions, but I want to
focus on some of the important ones from Bernie's
housing. For all proposal. There will be one,
nearly one and a half trillion dollars spent
over 10 years to build and renovate nearly
seven and a half million affordable housing
units in mixed income developments as well
as $400 billion for 2 million mixed income
social housing units for desegregation and
integration.
Boston actually does some of this where affordable
housing units are, uh, placed the, you might
have a 12 unit, um, development and a certain
number of those are designated affordable,
which helps to integrate rather than segregate
people on the basis of income. It's not perfect,
but it does do that to a great degree. Uh,
Bernie would expand. USDA is section five,
one five by $500 million to build affordable
units in rural areas as well as protect affordable
units, uh, existing affordable units. Very
important. You know, we talked about how can
a Democrats appeal to rural voters. I'm going
to deal with this more on tomorrow's show
as well. This is a great idea to go along
those lines. Indian housing block grants will
be increased to $3 billion. In total funding.
There will be $70 billion allocated to repair
and update public housing including high speed
broadband, which is important.
We've talked about broadband as a, uh, having
it versus not having it is, is increasingly
a segregating factor economically. Uh, the
fair cloth amendment will be repealed. That
amendment prevents building new public housing
in certain situations via a g n d we will,
uh, the green new deal that is there will
be the electrification and decarbonization
of public housing, which is both a good for
the climate and also good for the people who
are in public housing. Uh, section eight rental
assistance will be fully funded at the rate
of $410 billion over 10 years. Make sense?
There will be a strengthening of the fair
housing act and the addition of a nondiscrimination
law. This a small area fair market rent rule
will be expanded and there will be $2 billion
via the USDA combined with $6 billion via
HUD for a first time home buyer program. First
time home buyer programs have existed for
a long time, but the idea is let's increase
it, let's, um, strengthen it in order to deal
with the high cost of living that still keeps
people who are just a little bit too wealthy
to qualify for some of these programs from
buying.
We can enable them to, uh, become first time
home buyers as well, and then end the mass
sale of mortgages to Wall Street. This is
something a lot of people don't even know
happens, but very often there are lots of
banks who you will take out a mortgage with
them and very soon thereafter they will sell
the mortgage to a big Wall Street firm. This
is an extraordinarily speculative activity.
It doesn't benefit the consumer. Uh, and many
people don't even know it happens because
often the originating bank will continue servicing
the loan. So what's, what's not often discussed
and may not be obvious to those slamming Bernie
for wanting to quote, spend your money with
a proposal like this because people haven't
earned it. As we often hear from right wingers,
there is a morality argument to make, which
is that we are an extraordinarily rich country.
Ending homelessness is merely a matter of
deciding to end it. Not a matter of having
to figure out really complicated ways to do
it. We know exactly how to do it. Let's say
you don't care about the morality. Homelessness
has insane economic costs that are quote,
socialized among all of us. Homeless people
are more likely for a variety of reasons to
end up in the emergency room uninsured that
costs you money. Homeless people are more
likely to get arrested for marginal crimes
that are associated with homelessness and
that filled jails costing us tax dollars.
Um, that it's, it's, we could go into many
examples of that and we have, but that costs
you money. Homeless people have more difficulty
finding jobs. Not having an address makes
it harder to find a job. Not having a stable
place to live makes it harder to keep a job
and to do well in that job.
Meaning that homeless people don't earn wages,
meaning they don't pay taxes into state and
local governments, which is not good for any
of us. Being homeless is really expensive
for society and providing not just a home,
but I would argue also a medical care as we've
talked about for the last 10 years on the
show is cheaper for you in the long run. If
you don't care about the morality of it. If
you don't care about the people as people,
then maybe you care about the finances of
it and it will save you money to do something
like what Bernie Sanders is proposing here.
The other financial thing here is that lots
of these components that Bernie proposes are
what we call demand side stimulus, construction,
energy retrofits, service providers of all
kinds are involved, companies of all kinds
are involved. That is an entire additional
front of economic stimulus that is in addition
to everything else that we're talking about.
Uh, and so on. All Fronts. This really makes
sense. It's a great plan. No plan is perfect,
but I hope that other candidates will develop
similar plans and uh, that if we get a Democratic
president replacing Donald Trump, that this
is one of the first things they deal with
because it will be good not only for the homeless
people that will directly benefit. This will
be good for the economy. This'll be good for
neighborhood safety. This will be good in
every way that we can imagine.